what's going on guys
we here at screen junkies are very
excited to be a part of breaks prank and
forward movement which rewards deserving
people with positive pranks and we knew
there was only one person that we wanted
to prank our number one fan
Devon Coulson this young man is a movie
buff a Marvel fanatic and he floods us
with positive comments on every single
thing we do we decided to fly to Devon's
house in College Station Texas to give
him the ultimate screen junkies
experience and a mind-blowing Marvel
surprise
I just saw a real live Texas horse
neither yo what if he's like I wish I
wish Nick was here instead of you how
wouldn't surprise me the kid loves
Monday so we are at Devon Coulson's
house he is not home we are meeting with
his mom right now I'm gonna ring the
doorbell our cameraman is walking
backwards I'm hoping he doesn't trip
over the stones in the walkway it's a
very exciting day my name is Laura
Coulson
I am Devon Coulson's mom do you think
he's gonna be excited about us being
here today
I think that he will be so shocked and
excited that you guys are here today
that it may not show on the outside but
on the inside he is just beside himself
that's just kind of his nature while
Devon was away at school we transformed
his living room into a full-blown scream
junkie show set with the transformation
complete there was only one thing left
to do surprise Devon I'm actually
getting a little nervous
I'm more nervous waiting for Devon right
now and then I was going in to talk to
Robert De Niro and Morgan Freeman
we got to get this just right we're
about to make this kid's day
hi are you Devin yes do you know who I
am nothing I am Hal Rudnick what did you
expect to find me here no not in it
Devin must be you it is great to meet
you you know what we are here pranking
it forward we know you're a huge fan may
be the biggest fan of screen junkies and
honest trailers there is you want to
give me a tour of the Casa del heaven I
wish I could film an actual screen
junkies episode with you but
unfortunately you know the studio and
everything we need is back well that
would be awesome though yeah oh oh yeah
what that's what I'm talking about so we
are going to shoot an episode of screen
junkies right here with you as our star
guest what were you gonna do this
afternoon watch a little TV mm-hmm
what's uh what were we gonna watch on TV
well it's next Tuesday so Tuesday nights
flash and agents of shield does it feel
like you're in a dream right now
yes yes it does I never want to wake up
the screen junkie show with screen
junkies superfan Devon Colson we are
here in the home of our biggest fan
Devon Colson sitting next to Devon is my
good friend the creator of honest
trailers mr. Andy signal yeah and I'm so
excited to be here with our number one
fan Devon awesome to meet you thank you
for the support before I get into the
show um the panel feels a little light I
think maybe we could use one more who
would you want to come
Nick Monday ah I wish only we could
summon Nick mundi mundi I'm in this
bathroom for five hours waiting for him
to come out hey guys I hear it it's not
here yet so he's gonna come in here I
think you're gonna wait in there what
the bathroom just keep the door closed
actually turn the light off too I always
wanted to do that so let me throw out
today's screen junkies topic we are
gonna break it down what is the best of
the latest slew of Marvel movies so uh
Nick let's start down on the end with
you what do you like my favorite Marvel
movie is Captain America Winter Soldier
Devon what is your favorite Marvel movie
and guardians of the galaxy movie it's
unlike anything we've ever seen like a
cross between that Marvel and Star Wars
that MIT had become best friends that's
a really concise good way to put anyone
inside the net yeah yeah if we've proved
anything beyond the shadow of a doubt
Devon Coulson is smarter than Nick
Monday I could have told you no we'd
have to go to Texas Andy uh what's your
favorite my favorites gotta be Iron Man
just because I feel like it established
the Marvel Canon yeah I built Robert
Downey jr. his tone just everything
about the casting choice all that stuff
just came together so perfectly yeah how
what's yours I gotta go Avengers so many
mouths to feed in that movie and making
it all come together and one of the best
action movies possible and providing a
villain that we love to hate there
aren't a lot of great villains in the
Marvel Universe okay Devin very curious
since you're such a big Marvel fan what
a Marvel character would you like to see
that's not hasn't been announced in a
movie
a cloak-and-dagger nice he's legit
Marvel yeah you are a legend horrible
man and I think you can't lose when you
pick any of the four movies we picked
except andis but um right yeah it's too
hard but Devon you know what we'll give
it to you guardians of the galaxy the
best Marvel movie because it's your day
brother and now since we came here for
prank it forward because you are a huge
screen junkies fan on social media when
we post our stuff to Twitter and
Facebook you are always the first one to
like it well we just we just really
appreciate it and then since we're close
from the same hometown I just want to
give you this so we can match oh yeah
and if it doesn't fit either receiving
skulls and does it fast fine nice how I
think we can do better than that we do
have something uh very special for you
we have a number of things for you all
this stuff we brought down and you know
we're taking it back with us but
actually no we're not we're giving you
every toy I see in this room yeah all
these toys are compliments of our
friends at loot crate and we had a
custom piece of screen junkies honest
trailer aren't made for you um and Dan
get that from my good friend Dan Merle
some special friends of the show we
reached out to you wanted to give you a
special let's go ahead pretty play hi
Devin Devin Devin I think you know my
friends Chloe Bennet make now when I'm
Clark Gregg I play Phil Coulson on
agents of shield and elsewhere we
understand that you are a brother
Coulson and our friends at screen junkie
say you're a big fan of the show so we'd
like to thank you for your support it
inspires us to do our best work thank
you thank you have you
I can transactions for Megan demonstrate
come through without our fans this show
would be nothing and you have proven to
us time and time again that you are a
great fan of the show and we thank you
for Devon Colson the entire Colson
family Nick Lundy Andy signor I'm Hal
Rudnick hit me up on Twitter thanks for
watching bye bye bye how often is it
that somebody comes by and showers you
with gifts and and appreciate you like
this it's a once-in-a-lifetime type of
thing wow that was awesome
to see another amazing prank click on
she's got it made in the box above where
prank at foam word presents one
hard-working mom with a life-changing
surprise the more you click watch and
share the more money prank it forward
raises for dosomething.org thanks again
to loot crate for the awesome toys to
win a six month subscription to loot
crate follow Devon Coulson on Twitter
and he will pick a random winner thanks
for watching bye bye